hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to in 2007
a little movie came out called Juno it
was a comedy about a suburban high
school girl who gets pregnant decides to
give it to another person and all the
pros and cons of going through such an
experience critics seem to like it
it puts several young actors and
actresses on the map and the audience
reception seem to be good too
actually really good like every fucking
person was talking about this movie for
a really really long time
have you seen Juno you gotta see Juno it
opened my eyes to so many goddamn
fucking things really this quirky little
comedy about pregnant teenage girl well
okay it may not be Oscar worthy and
everything but holy shit it seems to be
Oscar worthy and everything winning Best
Original Screenplay and nominated for
three others including Best Picture god
damn this movie was on fire for a while
but as his popularity got bigger and
bigger then came the inevitable backlash
but this is a like Twilight backlash or
transformers backlash where a certain
audience hated it from the very
beginning this was a backlash from its
very own fans the movie didn't change it
remained exactly the same as it was
before with no sequel remakes or
anything like that being done yet the
same people who said they loved the film
just a few months ago were suddenly
revisiting it and realizing maybe it
wasn't the big game changer that they
thought it was the term jus knowing it
started to come about meaning when you
look back at something you thought you
loved but then realized it wasn't that
great to begin with though the film is
still well-known thoughts about it still
remain kind of jumbled wasn't really a
groundbreaking film or do we all get
wrapped up in the moment of a movie
coming out in the right culture at the
right time I'll admit I was kind of
shocked at the attention the film was
suddenly getting I actually thought the
directors previous comedy thank you for
smoking was much more groundbreaking it
took a lot more chances I think for many
people it struck a chord because a story
like this had never really been told
quite in this way oh don't get me wrong
the story of somebody giving birth is
old as time itself but this film seemed
to come at it from a slightly different
point of view
most comedies of this nature focus on
the adults and how much they overreact
to the pregnancy but here not only is
the focus on the girl who got pregnant
but the parents have a totally calm if
not surprisingly logical talk about it I
didn't even know you were sexually
active who is the father
it's Paulie Bleeker Paulie Bleeker what
I don't think you had anything I know
right
you're thinking about adoption yeah yeah
there's no tears there's no screaming
there's well none of the stuff that you
normally see in movies and this reaction
alone took a lot of people by surprise
is this how it is now parents don't even
get that angry when this stuff happens
well wait maybe the idea is they know
she's already putting herself through
enough heartache over this that they
know not to make the pain even worse is
that it was that the intention it's hard
to say what exactly they were going for
and whether or not they're supposed to
be accepted as these great logical
parents or these terrible under caring
parents but whatever your thought this
reaction seemed to be the kickoff to the
movies very different tone the tone
being that the hardships of teen
pregnancy aren't ignored they're just
kind of looked at as very commonplace
again many people debated is this really
how it is now and if so should it be
this way is it better to be calmer and
more collected over this situation
or is it being so easygoing that they're
emphasizing it was never that big a deal
to begin with this is part of the debate
that splits people into the lover hate
camps another part of that debate the
writing many people praised the writer
for capturing the language of our youth
while others say it's pretty gimmicky
and ridiculously awkward Juna no it's
Morgan Freeman you have any bones that
need collecting what honest blog for
shiz up the spat the character of Juna
herself is a lover hater scenario many
claim that she's rather grating to
listen to trying to look cool and pouty
throughout the whole experience I think
that's kind of true but I also think
it's intentional a lot of kids around
that age try to act like an obvious big
deal it's not an obvious big deal
it's their way of dodging emotion then
yeah times can be a little annoying but
for some it's not bad enough for
her to be unlikable or more importantly
unrelatable another factor though is the
moment I like to call what the fuck are
you doing moments these are pretty
self-explanatory the moments of a quirky
film that are trying so goddamn hard to
be quirky and different that you just
say what the fuck are you doing
wicked Tiger looks proud I swiped it
from his Rancic's lung what the fuck are
you doing I just see a lot of teenage
mothers come through here it's obviously
a poisonous environment to raise a baby
oh fuck are you doing there what the
fuck are you doing how do you think of
me you know why are you over here yeah
all of these moments never seem to
further anything and never seemed needed
they just seem to exist to give the
movie a quirky identity or just to do
something different that you didn't see
coming even with the underground art
house comic drawings the short use of
them really doesn't seem to add much to
the movies identity outside of just
clarifying that the movie wants an
identity those elements just don't seem
essential this doesn't seem like a movie
that heavily needs to ride its style
it's good enough just to ride on the
characters and tone alone but that still
brings up the question does it ride on
its character and tone alone looking
back I think one of the reasons people
gravitated towards it is because so many
people thought this was speaking for all
current teen pregnancies this is how it
is this is how pregnant teens want to be
and should be treated it's a handbook
for how to deal with such a largely
visible taboo but truth be told I don't
think it should be looked at like that
every pregnancy is different no matter
what age or background and everybody is
going to have a different way of
responding to it to say this movie is
speaking for an entire generation of
young people seems Kali Bleeker is
totally boss geez bananas shut your
friggin gob okay
pretty damn silly but I think if it's
looked at as not how all teen
pregnancies go but rather how just this
one went it still seems like a decent
flag there's a lot of hard a lot of good
intent
Shen's and even some pretty good
performances snuck in there with that
said it shouldn't be a surprise that
somebody doesn't like it it has a lot of
unneeded gimmicks that seem to date it
with every passing year but I don't know
if there's enough to make it hate worthy
if it's seen as the voice of pregnant
teenagers all over the world it's
probably building up a false expectation
but if it's seen as the voice of one
pregnant teenager the one we're focusing
on in this film
I think it's innocent enough will it be
seen as a cinematic classic years from
now I guess only time can tell on that
one but hey if the word bots can come
back into style fuck it I guess the
birth of anything is totally possible
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
because I fucking want that hamburger
phone somebody get me that hamburger
phone I'm not leaving until you do cut
to the credits he even makes it
you